If you would would you walk us through a typical day for you? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Today we're talking about finding meaning in our work. I generally come in at least 15 minutes late. I use the side door that way lumber can't see me and After that I just sort of space out for about an hour. This clip from the movie Office Space describes what work feels like to many people, not the stuff of poetry. But now imagine something that feels more than just a job, something that feels like a calling.
如果你能，你能跟我们讲讲你典型的一天是怎么度过的吗？这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们来探讨如何在工作中寻找意义。我通常会迟到至少15分钟。我走侧门，这样伐木工就看不到我了，之后我差不多有一个小时都在发呆。电影《办公空间》里的这个片段描述了许多人对工作的感受，这可不是什么诗意的产物。但现在，想象一下那种感觉不仅仅是一份工作，而更像是某种天职的感觉。
What we learned is people who see their work as a calling are significantly more satisfied with their jobs, they're significantly more satisfied with their lives. They're more engaged in what it is that they're doing and tend to be better performers regardless of what the work is. This week on Hidden Brain, a conversation with Amy Riznowski, professor of organizational behavior at the Yale School of Management. Amy studies work and something that she calls job crafting. Job crafting can help you make the job that you have right now, more meaningful and more satisfying.
我们了解到的是，那些将工作视为天职的人，对工作的满意度要显著高得多，对生活的满意度也显著高得多。他们对所做的事情投入度更高，无论工作内容是什么，往往表现也更好。本周的《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们将对话耶鲁大学管理学院组织行为学教授艾米·日兹诺夫斯基。艾米一直在研究工作以及她所谓的“工作重塑”。工作重塑能帮你把你现在的工作变得更有意义、更令人满意。
Amy Riznowski, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. I was reading one of your papers recently and I was struck by an excerpt that you had at the top, one came from a corporate securities lawyer and one came from a tax adermist. And I was struck by what the two of them said. Can you tell me what they said? Sure.
艾米·日兹诺夫斯基，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。我最近在读你的一篇论文时，被你开篇的一段摘录打动了，其中一段来自一位企业证券律师，另一段来自一位标本剥制师。这两个人说的话深深触动了我。你能告诉我他们说了什么吗？当然可以。
So the corporate securities lawyer was bemoaning the fact that his job as he saw it was, I think his words were a deal with the devil, that he did the job not because he liked it, but because it allowed him to stay geographically in an area that worked for his family and so on. And in contrast, the taxidermist was talking about the way in which the kind of work he did, sometimes moved people to tears when they came and picked up the pieces that he had created for them,
那位企业证券律师当时在抱怨，在他看来，他的工作——我想他的原话是“与魔鬼做交易”——他做这份工作不是因为他喜欢，而是因为这能让他在地理位置上留在适合他家庭的地区等等。相比之下，那位标本剥制师则谈到了他所做的那种工作有时会让人感动得流泪，当他们来取他为他们制作的作品时，
and how for him the feeling of satisfaction that comes from work that has that kind of impact is one of the biggest things in his life. I have the paper in front of me that taxidermist said, I did a duck for a guy the other day. And when he came and picked it up, he almost started crying because it looked so nice. He was just so happy and that made me feel good
对他而言，从具有这种影响力的工作中获得的满足感是他生命中最重要的事情之一。我手头就有那篇论文，那位标本剥制师说：“我前几天为一个人做了一只鸭子。当他来取的时候，他几乎要哭出来了，因为看起来太漂亮了。他太高兴了，这让我感觉很好，
that he thought I'd done a good job. Self-satisfaction is a big deal in any job. It's a big deal in life. And I was so moved by that comment because of course if you just looked at those two jobs side by side you might assume that the corporate security is lawyer where the high profile fancy job is the person who's actually happier at work but that's not often the case. That's not often the case and in fact a good amount of the research that I've done has tried to look at how the experiences
因为他觉得我干得不错。”自我满足感在任何工作中都是一件大事。在生活中也是一件大事。这段评论深深打动了我，因为当然，如果你把这两份工作并排来看，你可能会以为身处高调、体面工作的企业证券律师才是真正在工作中更快乐的人，但事实往往并非如此。事实往往并非如此，事实上，我做的大量研究都试图去探讨这样一个问题：人们在工作中的体验，
that people have in their work, the ways in which they talk about it and come to think about its place in their lives, vary so much across the entire spectrum in ways that research hasn't necessarily recognized. When you went into a hospital some years ago and you looked at the people working as the cleaning staff of the hospital. You discovered something very interesting. You found that they did not all think of their jobs the same way. That's true.
他们谈论工作的方式、以及对工作在他们生活中地位的思考，在整个光谱中有着巨大的差异，而这种差异是研究未必意识到的。几年前，你走进一家医院，观察那些在医院做清洁工作的人。你发现了非常有趣的事情。你发现他们并不是所有人对自己的工作都有相同的看法。确实如此。
Our first clue about this was not necessarily in how they talked about the ways that they thought about the job, but in how it was that they described the tasks of their job. So on the one hand, we had this group of hospital cleaning staff members who described the work as being not very high skill. And another group who described it in very different terms and said, this was highly skilled work where it would be very difficult to bring others in and have them take over the job. And in looking to see what were the differences between these two groups of cleaners,
我们关于这一点的第一个线索，不一定在于他们谈论对工作的看法时怎么说，而在于他们如何描述自己工作中的任务。一方面，我们有一组医院清洁工，他们将工作描述为技术含量不高。而另一组则用非常不同的术语来描述，说这是一项高技术含量的工作，如果让其他人进来接替这项工作将会非常困难。在观察这两组清洁工之间有什么区别时，
we had no differences in the kind of shift that they worked. They're tenure in the organization, the kind of units they worked on and so on. Instead, what was different was what they described as being the kinds of things that they did during the daily course of the work. So in the first group, the cleaners who described the work as being not particularly high-skilled, they very much hude to the job description. And the job description, while extensive, doesn't involve a lot of interaction, in fact, any interaction, with patients, visitors, nurses, doctors, and so on. Presumably they were just swabbing floors, dusting, mopping, doing cleaning crew type stuff. Exactly.
我们在他们所做的工作班次、他们在组织中的资历、他们工作的科室等方面没有发现任何区别。相反，不同之处在于他们所描述的在日常工作过程中所做的事情。因此，在第一组中，那些将工作描述为技术含量不高的清洁工，他们非常严格地遵循职位描述。而职位描述虽然很广泛，却不涉及大量的互动，实际上，是根本不涉及与患者、访客、护士、医生等的互动。据推测，他们只是在擦地板、除尘、拖地，做清洁队类型的事情。完全正确。
And in the second group, they also talked about all of these kinds of things, but in addition, talked about the kinds of things that they did on a regular basis for and with nurses, doctors, patients, and patients, visitors. And we checked this multiple times, but this was not something that they were being asked to do. Often, these kinds of things were going beyond the notice of those who supervised them in the hospital in which they worked. But for the cleaners who engaged in this, we ended up calling this job crafting. They were crafting the boundaries of their jobs in
而在第二组中，他们也谈到了所有这些事情，但除此之外，还谈到了他们经常为护士、医生、患者以及患者访客所做的事情。我们多次核实过，但这不是别人要求他们做的事情。通常，这些事情超出了他们在医院里监督他们的管理人员的注意范围。但对于从事这些活动的清洁工来说，我们最终称之为“工作重塑”。他们在重塑自己工作的边界，
ways that we think made the work for them more meaningful, was something that they very much undertook on their own. If I remember correctly, some of the people who found their work especially difficult were in fact doing work that might be argued to be against the rules. Yes, so some of the things that the cleaning staff members in this part of our sample describe doing involved figuring out when would it be safe, for example, to give a patient a drink of water
我们认为这让他们的工作对他们而言更有意义，这是他们完全凭自己的意愿去做的。如果我没记错的话，有些觉得工作特别困难的人，实际上所做的事情可以说是违反规定的。是的，因此我们样本中这部分清洁工描述的一些事情，包括弄清楚什么时候安全，例如，给患者一杯水，
if they requested one, or when was it safe to give a patient a drink of water if they requested one, or when was it safe to help a patient to move or things like this, which moves into the realm of patient care and could very well get them into trouble. But the cleaning staff members we studied had developed systems of figuring out when was it safe to do these things. One was it okay to do these things versus when would it be necessary to go and get a member of the medical staff? You found one woman in particular
如果他们要求的话，或者什么时候给患者一杯水是安全的，或者什么时候帮助患者移动是安全的，诸如此类的事情，这就进入了患者护理的领域，很可能会给他们带来麻烦。但我们研究的清洁工已经建立了一套系统，用来弄清楚什么时候做这些事情是安全的。什么时候可以做这些事情，而什么时候又必须去叫医务人员？你发现了一位特别的女性，
who did something really interesting when it came to patients who were in a coma. Tell me what she did. So this particular staff member worked in essentially a long-term rehabilitation floor where patients were unconscious or comatose and hopefully would be emerging from those states. One of the things that she described doing was taking down the framed art prints, most patient rooms have
当遇到处于昏迷状态的患者时，她做了一件非常有趣的事情。告诉我她做了什么。这位特殊的员工主要在长期康复病房工作，那里的患者没有意识或处于昏迷状态，并有望从这些状态中苏醒过来。她描述自己做的事情之一就是取下带框的艺术印刷品，大多数患者病房都有某种印刷品或别的什么，
some kind of print or another, and she would take those down on a regular basis and rearrange them and rehang them. And when we asked her if this was part of her job or part of the duties that she was given in her job description, she answered that it was not, which was quite striking. And then asking more deeply about, well, why do this? Talked about the hope that even though patients were not necessarily aware of their surroundings,
她会定期把这些取下来，然后重新排列并重新挂上去。当我们问她这是否是她工作的一部分，或者是职位描述中赋予她的职责之一时，她回答说不是，这相当令人震惊。然后更深入地询问，为什么要做这个？她谈到了这样一种希望：尽管患者可能并不一定对周围环境有意识，
maybe some shift in the environment in which they were recuperating could spark something in them and speed their trajectory of healing. In some way she was behaving like we would behave toward a family member. You're trying to anticipate the needs of the person even before they're expressed. You're not following the letter of the law. You're actually trying to do everything you possibly can to ensure an outcome for someone you care about. Absolutely. And we saw a lot of evidence of this in our data.
也许他们康复环境中环境的某种改变能够激发他们体内的某些东西，并加快他们康复的进程。在某种程度上，她的行为就像我们对待家庭成员一样。你在试图预测这个人的需求，甚至在他们表达出来之前。你没有死板地墨守成规。你实际上是在尽你所能去确保你关心的人有一个好结果。绝对是的。我们在数据中看到了很多这样的证据。
So cleaning staff members who talked about getting in the room sort of aiming their face sort of skyward to look at the ceilings of the hospital rooms to see if there were things that were up there that we might not notice, but would bother the patients if the patients had to look at them all day long so that they could take care of any dirt or sort of issues up on the ceiling. And we also heard a lot from the cleaning staff members about looking at each patient, and in many cases patients' families,
因此，清洁工们谈到进入房间，把脸抬起看着医院病住房的天花板，看看上面有没有我们可能注意不到但如果患者整天盯着看会让他们心烦的东西，以便他们能够处理天花板上的任何污垢或类似问题。我们还听到清洁工们谈论很多关于审视每一位患者，在许多情况下还有患者的家属，
as though, well, this could be my father or my mother or my brother or sister, and how would I care for them? So there's two ways to look at these people who are doing things that are outside of that job description. You could call it at one level, you know, a form of insubordination. They're basically not following the rules at all. And you could say these are trouble-bakers and we want to make sure that we have as few of them as possible on the staff.
就好像，嗯，这可能是我的父亲、母亲、兄弟或姐妹，我会如何照顾他们？因此，看待这些做着超出职位描述事情的人有两种方式。你在某种程度上可以称之为一种不服从。他们基本上根本不遵守规则。你可能会说这些是麻烦制造者，我们希望确保员工中这样的人越少越好。
But you can also see them as people who are going the extra mile and really internalizing the larger mission of the hospital and not just the descriptions of their jobs. What did you find in terms of the outcomes of having workers who are the one kind or the other? Well, in this particular context, we were only gathering data about what it was that the hospital cleaning staff members said they were doing, and then what was that related to with respect to their experience on the job. We can only speculate as to what the outcomes were likely to be, but I would expect, for example, that particularly in a medical context, that it's hard to imagine that this wouldn't have had some kind of positive effect,
但你也可以把他们看作是那些付出额外努力、真正将医院的宏大使命内化而不仅仅局限于职位描述的人。在拥有前一种员工还是后一种员工的结果方面，你发现了什么？在这个特定的语境下，我们只收集了关于医院清洁工说他们在做什么的数据，以及这与他们在工作中的体验有什么关系。我们只能推测结果可能会是什么，但我会期望，例如，特别是在医疗语境下，很难想象这不会产生某种积极的影响，
because a lot of the things that the hospital cleaning staff members were talking about had to do with, in the course of their cleaning work, noticing who hadn't had a visitor in several shifts, who looked like they might be on the in several shifts, who looked like they might be on the verge of tears, who seemed like they really needed to talk, so that they could finish with their work and double back to spend time with those patients or with those patients' family members.
因为医院清洁工谈论的许多事情都与以下情况有关：在清洁工作的过程中，他们会注意到谁已经好几个班次没有人来探视了，谁看起来可能处于……好几个班次没有人来探视，谁看起来可能濒临落泪，谁看起来真的很需要找人聊聊，这样他们就可以完成手头的工作，然后折返回去花时间陪伴那些患者或患者的家属。
And it's hard to imagine that that kind of work doesn't have a positive impact in a context like that. I want to talk about what these different kinds of initiatives mean for the workers, but I want to just spend one second again looking at it from the point of view of the patient, which is that I think all of us in some ways have been in the shoes of those patients. May not be, you know, patients in a coma at the hospital, but we've been students in a class or, you know, going to the DMV to get a driver's license. And all of us have routinely encountered people who are there just doing their jobs
很难想象这种工作在这样的语境下不会产生积极的影响。我想谈谈这些不同类型的倡议对员工意味着什么，但我只想再花一秒钟从患者的角度来看待这个问题，那就是我认为我们所有人都曾在某种程度上设身处地为那些患者着想过。可能不是医院里昏迷的患者，但我们曾是课堂上的学生，或者去车管所办驾照。我们所有人都经常遇到那些仅仅是在那里做着工作的人，
and they're because they really find some deeper meaning in their jobs. I remember a chemistry teacher that I had in high school. I wasn't particularly fond of chemistry but the teacher was so inspired by the fact that chemistry was just the coolest subject in the universe that he communicated some of that excitement and enthusiasm to me and I knew that he wasn't just doing a job teaching me chemistry. This was something he desperately and deeply wanted to do. And I feel like all of us have these experiences. And when we come in contact with these people,
而他们之所以在那里，是因为他们在工作中找到了更深层的意义。我记得我高中时的一位化学老师。我并不是特别喜欢化学，但这位老师受到化学是宇宙中最酷的学科这一事实的极大启发，他将这种兴奋和热情传递给了我，我知道他不仅仅是在教我化学这份工作。这是他拼命想要并且深深热爱去做的。我觉得我们所有人都有过这样的经历。当我们与这些人接触时，
we feel like we are now in touch with the higher purpose of what this organization is supposed to be about. I think that's very well put, very well said, and I completely agree. And in fact, the line of research I was involved in that led to this study, originally started with exactly this question, how do people who are doing exactly the same job and the same organization come to see that work in such radically different terms, where some of them see it as you put it as just a job versus seeing the work perhaps more as a career.
我们觉得我们现在正触及这个组织本应具备的更高宗旨。我觉得这表达得非常好，非常贴切，我完全同意。事实上，我参与并导致这项研究的那条研究路线，最初正是从这样一个问题开始的：为什么在同一个组织里做着完全相同工作的人，会以如此截然不同的方式来看待这项工作，其中一些人如你所说，仅仅把它看作是一份工作，而另一些人则可能把工作看作是一项事业。
And then finally, people for whom that exact same work is something more akin to a calling. And these differences have always fascinated me where they come from, what the implications are for the individuals who do the work and for the organizations that they're a part of. In the second half of my conversation with Amy, we talk about what you can do to feel more engaged at work. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Today, I'm talking with Amy Riznowski about how we can find meaning in work.
最后，对这些人来说，完全相同的工作更类似于一种天职。这些差异一直令我着迷，它们从何而来，对从事这份工作的人以及他们所属的组织意味着什么。在我与艾米的对话的下半部分，我们探讨了你可以做些什么来让工作投入度更高。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天，我与艾米·日兹诺夫斯基探讨了我们如何在工作中寻找意义。
I asked Amy what she'd found about people who think of their work as a calling. What we learned is people who see their work as a calling are significantly more satisfied with their jobs, they're significantly more satisfied with their lives. They work more hours, they miss fewer days of work, they're more engaged in what it is that they're doing. So when we look at these two different kinds of people in the workplace, and I think what we often say is, this person just happened to find the organization that suits him or her, that it's just happenstance and luck that people find their calling.
我问艾米，她对那些将工作视为天职的人有什么发现。我们了解到的是，那些将工作视为天职的人，对工作的满意度要显著高得多，对生活的满意度也显著高得多。他们工作时间更长，请假天数更少，对自己所做的事情投入度更高。因此，当我们审视职场中这两种不同类型的人时，我想我们经常说的是，这个人只是恰好找到了适合他或她的组织，人们找到自己的天职纯粹是巧合和运气。
What I find really interesting and intriguing about your work is that you suggest that they might actually be a more deliberate process involved so that more of us can find our work to be a calling. It's a wonderful contrast that you draw here because I do think that there are two different schools of thought in play around callings. And one is that it's out there, you have to find it. It's a matter of moving into the right role or the right position and the right organization and so on.
我觉得你的工作真正有趣和引人入胜的地方在于，你认为其中实际上可能涉及一个更有意识的过程，这样我们当中更多的人才能发现我们的工作是一项天职。你在这里画出了一个极好的对比，因为我确实认为围绕天职存在着两个不同的思想学派。其中一种观点认为它就在那里，你必须去找到它。这是一个进入正确的角色、正确的岗位、正确的组织等等的问题。
And then suddenly this will be unlocked and your work will be this sort of joyful end in and of itself, which is very different from a view that I've come to, which is that can certainly happen where people can stumble into something and realize this is what I would do, even if I hit come to, which is that can certainly happen where people can stumble into something and realize this is what I would do even if I hit the lottery versus how is it that I can craft the boundaries of this job and the way that I think about its role in the world in such a way that I can come to experience perhaps as something that is meaningful in
然后突然之间，这一切就会被解锁，你的工作将成为这种本身就是快乐终点的存在，这与我得出的观点截然不同——这种情况当然会发生，人们可能会偶然撞上某件事并意识到这就是我要做的，即使我中了大奖——而另一种观点是，我该如何重塑这份工作的边界，以及我如何看待它在世界上的角色的方式，以便我能体验到它或许是一件有意义的事情，
a way that potentially a calling could be. One of the interesting things that happened recently is that we had this major power ball lottery that a lot of people got excited about. And our CEO at NPR bought everyone in the company lottery tickets and so we spent the day speculating what would be like to win $200 million. But what I found most interesting was that we asked several people, would you quit your job if you won this money? And I found it very revealing what people's answers were. So some people unhesitatingly said, of course, I'd quit my job. Why in the world would I
在某种程度上可能像是一项天职。最近发生的一件有趣的事情是，我们遭遇了这起大型强力球彩票开奖，许多人都为此兴奋不已。我们在NPR的首席执行官给公司里的每个人都买了一张彩票，于是我们花了一整天的时间猜测赢得2亿元会是什么感觉。但我发现最有趣的是，我们问了几个人：如果你中了这笔钱，你会辞职吗？我发现人们的回答极具启发性。因此，有些人毫不犹豫地回答：当然，我会辞职。我到底为什么要
keep working if I had $200 million in the bank? And other people had exactly the opposite response, which was sort of complete bewilderment. Why in the world would I quit my job when I'm doing something that I really enjoy doing? And I think it speaks exactly to what you're saying here, the people who are working because the work is an end in itself and the people who are working because the work is a means to an end. I think that seeing that divide and seeing that for even in the same exact job that the work can mean such different things to different people doing, doing that work often with the same level of education, same level of pay and so on, is fascinating to me. And I think, you know, given the choice, I think what we're seeing now is many people as they grow up
如果我银行里有2亿元还要继续工作？而另一些人则有着完全相反的反应，可以说是完全困惑。我到底为什么要辞职，当我正在做一件我真正享受的事情时？我认为这恰恰说明了你在这里所说的话，那些为了工作而工作、工作本身就是目的的人，以及那些因为工作是达到目的的手段而工作的人。我认为看到这种分歧，并看到即使在完全相同的工作中，对于做这份工作的人来说，工作也可以对不同的人意味着如此截然不同的事情，而这些人往往有着相同的教育水平、相同的薪酬水平等等，这让我着迷。并且我认为，你知道，如果有得选的话，我想我们现在看到的是，许多人在成长过程中，
and it's time to, you know, come to think about what they want to do in their work, are yearning for something that will feel a bit more like a job that you wouldn't necessarily want to quit if you hit the lottery. But I think that that's, depending on your theory of how these things work, if you think it's a magical unicorn out there that you just have to find, I think that that can be quite anxiety provoking for people. So if finding one of these great jobs is not one of these magical things that happens, or it is a magical thing that can happen, but it's also something that can be crafted, as you suggest, what's the way to do it?
到了考虑自己想在工作中做什么的时候，他们渴望有一种工作感觉更像是那种即使中了大奖你也不一定想辞职的工作。但我认为，这取决于你对这些事情运作原理的理论，如果你认为这是一个神奇的独角兽，你只需要去找到它，我认为这会给人们带来相当大的焦虑。因此，如果找到这些好工作不是那种会发生的魔法事件，或者它是一件可能发生的魔法事件，但正如你所建议的那样，这也是可以被重塑的东西，那么方法是什么呢？
Well, I mean, I think that part of what is involved is thinking about what kinds of things do people feel they very much enjoy and that they think are important in the world, whether those are tasks that have to get done because they help the world function in a way that is a real benefit to society or to other people to see how and where might you start to do things to make that work your own in a way that could feel even more fulfilling. You've also looked at efforts to try and change what it is the job itself is. So you get hired for a job, you're maybe a typist or maybe you're a computer programmer or you're maybe a manager, but then you can start working to expand the contours of what the job description actually is.
嗯，我的意思是，我认为其中涉及的一部分是思考人们觉得他们非常享受且认为对世界重要的事情是什么，无论是那些必须完成的任务，因为它们帮助世界以对社会或其他人真正有利的方式运转，去看看如何以及在哪里可以开始做一些事情，以你自己的方式让这项工作变得甚至能带来更多成就感。你也探讨了试图改变工作本身内容的努力。所以你被聘用做一份工作，你可能是一名打字员，或者你可能是一名电脑程序员，或者你可能是一名经理，但随后你可以开始努力扩大职位描述的实际轮廓。
Yes. One of the things that's interesting that I want to point out is that it's not only about expanding what those boundaries are and taking on more and doing more. Job crafting can also involve restricting that boundary, if you will. So maybe delegating or even pulling back or dropping some of the tasks that may be defined as part of the job, that over time people perhaps come to realize are not actually central to getting done or executing on the kinds of things that the organization feels that they ought to be responsible for. Now a lot of people feel like they don't have the latitude to make those changes, that I'm stuck. My manager
是的。我想指出的一件有趣的事情是，它不仅仅是关于扩大这些边界、承担更多和做得更多。工作重塑也可以涉及限制这种边界，如果你愿意的话。所以也许是授权，甚至是退回或放弃一些可能被定义为工作一部分的任务，随着时间的推移，人们可能会意识到这些任务实际上并不是完成或执行组织认为他们应该负责的事情的核心。现在很多人觉得他们没有做出这些改变的自由度，我被困住了。我的经理
won't allow me to modify what I'm doing. There are ways that I can see I can be more productive and more useful to the organization, but I feel constrained and hemmed in. Those are real concerns. They absolutely are. And even in jobs where this kind of crafting is explicitly forbidden, you still see people engaging in it. And I think it usually works like this. You recognize what it is that the organization expects you to accomplish. And you see, where do you have the degrees of freedom that you might take advantage of to do that in a way that maybe from a process point of view or from how you order the tasks point of view or who you interact with to get that work done point of view, how you can essentially customize that in a way that makes the experience more enjoyable, more meaningful, and something
不允许我修改我正在做的事情。我可以看到有些方法能让我更有效率、对组织更有用，但我感到受到限制和束缚。这些都是切实担忧。它们绝对是的。甚至在明确禁止这种重塑的工作中，你仍然会看到人们在从事它。我想它通常是这样运作的。你认识到组织期望你完成的是什么。然后你看看，你在哪里拥有可以利用的自由度，以便以某种方式完成它，也许从流程的角度，或者从你排列任务顺序的角度，或者从你与谁互动来完成这项工作角度来看，你如何本质上定制它，使体验更加愉快、更有意义，并让你
that perhaps makes you feel more connected to those who you're either working with or who are the recipients or beneficiaries of your work. I'm also fascinated by the fact that you point out that it's not just crafting your job description that can allow you to find work that's a calling, but it's also Recrafting or redefining the relationships you have with other people in the workplace. Can you talk about that for a moment? Most jobs involve some level of contact with or interdependence with other people whether those are co-workers whether those are clients or customers. It's often these relationships and these interdependencies with other people on the job that are the sources of the greatest joys and the greatest frustrations. And so in some sense doesn't surprise me that part of what it is that people are crafting are exactly that element.
也许感觉与那些与你共事的人、或者你工作的接受者或受益者联系更紧密。我也很着迷于你指出的这一点：不仅重塑你的职位描述可以让你找到作为天职的工作，而且重塑或重新定义你在职场中与其他人建立的关系也可以。你能谈谈这个吗？大多数工作都涉及与其他人的一定程度的接触或相互依存，无论是同事，还是客户或顾客。通常正是这些关系和工作中与其他人的相互依存，成为了最大快乐和最大挫折的源泉。所以在某种意义上，人们重塑的正是这一要素，这并不让我感到惊讶。
So the relationships and the interactions that are either necessary to executing the worker just come part and parcel with the doing of the job? You also talk in your research about the idea of cognitive crafting that besides changing the description of the job and the nature of the relationships around the job, there's also the way you think about the job, which in many ways is perhaps the thing you have the greatest control over. You have some ability to change what it is you're doing in how you come to think about what you're doing. Yes, so the third form of crafting, so you can craft the tasks that comprise the job, the relationships and interactions that are part of the job, but this third category that you name cognitive crafting consists of how it is that people think about what the
所以，那些执行工作所必需的或者只是伴随着工作进行的各种关系和互动？你在研究中还探讨了“认知重塑”的概念，即除了改变工作的描述和工作周围关系的性质之外，还有你对工作的看法，这在许多方面也许是你拥有最大控制权的事情。你有一定能力改变你对正在做的事情的看法。是的，所以第三种重塑形式是——你可以重塑构成工作的任务、作为工作一部分的关系和互动，但你命名的第三个类别——认知重塑，包括人们如何看待工作究竟
work even is. And it turns out that there's a lot of freedom in this, if you will, to go back to the hospital cleaning staff study. One of the questions that we asked the hospital cleaning staff members we interviewed was to give us your job title here. Some of the people in that study gave us their official technical title. Other people would say things like, I'm an ambassador or in the most extreme case of someone sort of deviating if you will
是什么。事实证明，这里面有很大的自由度，如果借用医院清洁工的研究来说。我们在采访医院清洁工时问的一个问题是，请告诉我们你这里的职位职称。研究中的一些人告诉了我们他们的官方技术职称。其他人则会说这样的话，比如，“我是个大使”，或者在最极端的情况下，有人在某种程度上偏离了
from describing the work the way that the organization would said, I'm a healer. One of the things that excites us about the job crafting work is that these different ways of engaging in cognitive crafting seems to be related to how it is that people actually then go about executing the job, right? If you have that uniform on and you're on your shift and you are thinking of yourself as a healer, that that is your responsibility and your role there. It's very different from thinking about it in terms of working through a particular task set in a day. And again, sort of where those differences come from, why some people do this, why others
组织所期望的方式来描述工作，说：“我是个治疗师。”关于工作重塑，令我们兴奋的事情之一是，这些不同形式的认知重塑似乎与人们实际执行工作的方式有关，对吧？如果你穿着那套制服，在值班，并且你认为自己是一名治疗师，那是你的责任和角色。这与仅仅考虑一天中完成一组特定的任务有着截然不同的感受。同样，这些差异从何而来，为什么有些人这样做而其他人
don't, and the difference that it makes for them is something that's been endlessly fascinating for us. Amy Riznowski, thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me, it's been a pleasure. That's Amy Riznowski, professor of organizational behavior at the Yale School of Management. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karamagore Callison, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak, all of whom love their jobs. You can find us on Facebook and Twitter and listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes.
不这样做，以及它对他们产生的影响，对我们来说一直是一个令人着迷的话题。艾米·日兹诺夫斯基，感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我，这真是个荣幸。这位是艾米·日兹诺夫斯基，耶鲁大学管理学院的组织行为学教授。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉马戈尔·卡利森、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作，他们都热爱自己的工作。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这期节目，请考虑在iTunes上给我们写个评价。
It will help other people find the podcast. I'm Shankar Vidantan. I also love my work, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这会帮助其他人找到这个播客。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我也热爱我的工作，这里是NPR。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。